When Alice came to the house, she saw the Hatter and the Hare having a tea party.
It was a large table and only three creatures were sitting around it.
However, as Alice walked towards it, they cried,...
..."No room! No room!"
"Nonsense," said Alice, "there's plenty of room."
"Why is a raven like a desk?" The Hatter asked.
Alice liked riddles.
"I believe I can guess that," she said.
"Do you mean," the Hare asked,...
..."that you think you can find the answer to that riddle?"
"Yes," Alice answered.
"Then, you should say what you mean." the Hare said.
"I usually do," Alice said,...
..."and I mean what I say."
"That's the same thing."
"Have you guessed the answer to the riddle yet?" The Hatter asked.
"No, I give up," Alice told him.
"I don't know either." the Hatter said.
"Neither do I." the Hare said.
"Haven't you anything better to do than ask riddles that have no answer?"
Alice asked angrily.